the paper airplane you folded in middle
school
horrible design
but i've thrown a paper airplane 214
feet
i'm john collins i am the paper airplane
guy world record holder for paper
aircraft distance
so the year we got the record was 2012.
it was uh you know one of the great days
in my life actually you know i i look
back at my child being born in the world
record those are great moments for me
i named the world record playing after
my wife the name of the design is
suzanne
this is how you fold suzanne you start
with the short side of the paper top of
the page and put it against the right so
now when you unfold that you've got an
accent after that is to take it right
straight down the top of the plan you
fold the plane in half it's just eight
simple folds
there are a lot of different kinds of
folding techniques and a lot of
different kinds of paper airplanes
there's planes that boomerang back
there are planes that are made to fly
straight very far there are planes that
are made to stay in the air for a long
time
every great paper airplane distance or
time aloft has very accurate folding
most people want to know how i got into
paper airplanes and the reality is i
never got out of them i am curious by
nature i love math and science the cool
thing about paper airplanes is it's a
way to actually discover something real
about flight
what most people don't know is that we
don't know the exact cause and effect
for lyft
every little paper airplane throw is
like a little science experiment here's
the laboratory right here in your hand
that you could use to do real science
teachers kind of don't like kids to do
paper airplanes it has this bad boy kind
of renegade reputation
if they could discover that paper
airplanes actually are science that
they're doing science and having fun
doing it i think that's an incredible
breakthrough
paper airplane throwing class yes